[Music]
not once
has a single black hole disturbed our
planetary routine
but what if it did
would this uninvited guest swallow up
everything on its way through the solar
system
or would it just slightly disrupt it
this
is what if and here's what would happen
if a black hole
appeared in our solar system black holes
aren't exactly holes
they're a large amount of matter that
has been crammed into a very small space
being so compressed gives them an
incredibly strong gravitational pull
not even light can escape a black hole's
grasp and if you get too close to a
black hole
you yourself would get compressed to an
infinitely small dot
a black hole entering our solar system
would not be good news
but just how bad would it be
the extent of the havoc that a single
black hole would wreak on the solar
system
depends on how big that black hole was
and how far into the solar system it got
if we're talking a super massive black
hole like the one residing at the center
of our milky way galaxy
our chances of survival are slim
a monster that size would cause us
trouble even from a distance of a few
light years away
presumably supermassive black holes have
stars
planets asteroids and comets orbiting
around them
all the debris that a supermassive black
hole picked up on its way through space
would bombard our solar system then
that gigantic black hole would tug
whatever was left into an orbit around
it
we'd be long gone by that time wiped out
by some rogue planet that smashed into
earth
let's try our chances with a stellar
black hole this
is a black hole that's up to 20 times
more massive than our sun
if this kind of black hole made it to
the outer reaches of the solar system
it would cause a gravitational mess in
the oort cloud the area of icy comet
like objects
a stellar black hole would hurl more
comets and asteroids into the inner
solar system where they could strike the
planets
earth might take some hits too but that
would be just a warm-up
as the black hole made its way through
the solar system it would disrupt the
orbits
of all the planets in it likely our
space intruder would tangle with the
biggest planet in the system
jupiter the black hole would pull all
the gas from the giant planet
turning it into a swirling hot disk
it would keep pulling until it consumed
jupiter entirely
what would happen to our own planet in
this gravitational mess
things wouldn't be good for earth the
black hole would start affecting us
even from a distance of pluto's orbit
first it would pull us out of the
habitable zone
and we humans might not be ready to
adapt to this change
we wouldn't have much time to complain
though since there would be worse things
ahead
as the black hole approaches earth it
would cause the cracking of the planet's
crust
we'd see extreme earthquakes and
volcanic eruptions
the ocean tides would be devastating too
by the time the black hole passed
earth's orbit
there would be nothing left of our
planet but a sterile surface
paved with magma maybe earth would be
ejected from the solar system altogether
that would probably be for the best
because when the black hole got
close enough to the sun it would start
drinking up the sun's flaming gas
and pulling our center of gravity into
its insatiable stomach
if somehow earth stuck around for the
after party it would be torn to shreds
and consumed by the black hole
luckily black holes don't seem to be
very numerous in the universe
the chances are better for a rogue
planet to enter our solar system
but that's a story for another what if